si certains prétendent quatre candidats
de télé réalité n'est pas un métier
zoubir le confirme
un homme de 25 ans qui participe en ce
moment au programme les princes et
princesses de l'amour sur w9 un vrai
métier à côté il est policier
voilà si sa prestation dans l'émission
fait sensation l'ambiance est beaucoup
moins légère du côté de sa hiérarchie
il apprécie visiblement pas beaucoup sa
participation au programme et ses
publications sur les réseaux sociaux
japon pour faire copain copain gpn la
police des polices aurait en effet reçu
un signalement via sa plateforme
selon les premières informations
révélées par le parisien la hiérarchie
du jeune homme n'aurait pas été avertis
des activités extra professionnelles du
jeune homme c'est le choc effet surprise
gt gt pas présent un mélange des genres
qui ne plaît pas beaucoup alors
comprenez vous que zoubir candidats de
télé-réalité et policiers soit sur la
sellette ce soir il est en direct avec
nous pour réagir à cette polémique et il
fera face à bruno pomart ancien patron
du raid
soupir qui est avec nous merci zoubir
d'être là merci alors toro tu le sais
j'y ai vu un petit coup de coeur pour
toi moi donc forcément je vais pas
donner mon avis hein parce que c'est
vrai que voilà j'ai fait j'aime bien ce
garçon il me fait rire
il est il est toujours y voilà je trouve
tes respectueux dans l'émission tu t'es
sympathique tu es drôle voilà donc je
t'aime bien tu le sais il ya mon ami
bruno pomart aussi j'aime la police
ignorait quel âge aiment la police
j'aime tout moi je moi je vais te dire
moi je suis je suis le médian chez le
médiateur des reprend mois médiateur du
médiateur négociateurs ou wells assure
mathieu si vous ne m'aimez pas d'en
dégoûter zoubir et avec lui les
policiers à paris dans le xvième
il est candidat des princes et les
princesses de la voix pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas les princes et les
princesses de l'amour la semaine
dernière zoubir vous avez fait votre
arrivée dans les princes et les
princesses de l'amour votre objectif t
séduire sarah parce que en fait cédé
objectif pas d'une oblique et de travail
dans les princes et les princesses de
l'amour c'est les objectifs de paix chad
regarder sous jean marie j'ai 25 ans je
crois que c'est la première fois que tu
veux faire courtiser par un [ __ ] laveur
du coup un latin lover
souvent c'est en fait ouais c'est bien
car ce garçon des conneries ce cas c'est
un mec plutôt sincère matures
donc à partir de maintenant à princesse
c'est toi alors zoubir donc été qui a
rejoint les princes et les princesses de
l'amour
alors pourquoi vous avez rejoint les
princes et les princesses de labour déjà
vous êtes dans la police on rappelle moi
débat ça faisait un petit moment qu'on
me disais voilà tel profil télé etc
c'est un petit moment j'avais envie de
voir ailleurs pour changer un petit peu
de domaines
ouais faire plaisir on me dit de revente
a le profil etc je me suis dit ça va
être l'occasion
voilà n'est pas nuire de voir à quelque
chose de nouveau et si en prime je peux
repartir avec une belle princesse bnf
non merci alors c'est à la suite de
cette apparition que les soucis aurait
commencé votre hiérarchie vous reproche
notamment de ne pas les avoir prévenus
est ce que vous aviez prévenu votre
hiérarchie que vous allez faire
les princes et les princesses de l'amour
non je ne sais pas prévenu que ça fait
un petit moment que déjà je suis en
rupture géant fracture avec avec
l'institution en général avec ma
hiérarchie ne les a pas prévenus
mais n'avait pas pris de l'allant selon
vous candidat et télé réalité et
policiers c'est compatible
moi mon avenir oui ça fait pas
l'unanimité mon avis c'est que ça peut
être compatible à partir du moment où
quand je vais dans ce genre de programme
se décline pas ma qualité de policier
mais à aucun moment j'ai décliné ma
qualité de policier à partir du moment
où je fais pas quelque chose de entre
guillemets indigne j'ai un comportement
assez noble on cherche l'amour voilà
pour moi pour moi c'est pas censé
apporter les porter préjudice alors oui
j'ai une question si vous permettez vous
avez dit que vous n'avez pas prévenu
votre hiérarchie et est ce que vous êtes
millions en maladie un arrêt maladie
alors le contexte s'il est plus
compliqué faut que je vous explique
depuis le néo c'est oui ou c'est non non
je vais vous expliquer depuis le début
interrogatoire non mais bon c'est le
comici remonter je vous explique en gros
mois j'ai pris un congé il ya un an en
début d'année en début 2000 va j'ai pris
un congé sans solde une dispo c'est à
dire qu'à partir de ce moment de jeu
dépend plus de la police je suis un peu
ce que je veux et c'est entre guillemets
un sujet pas plus de la police je ne
suis plus rémunérés quand j'ai fait ça
tu disposes c'était justement pour me
lancer dans le projet de mannequinat et
c'est ça n'a pas marché il ya ulcos vide
donc moi fallait que je remplisse le
frigo j'ai des charges et des loyers
je me suis retrouvé à rungis à bosser à
3 heures du matin dans le froid donc
appartenu moment à partir de ce moment
là je suis rentré je suis revenu dans la
police entre temps avant j'ai passé des
castings de télé j'ai passé les castings
1 2 3 j avais oublié je suis rentré dans
la police
j'ai repris et à ce moment là j'ai eu
des retours faut savoir qu'avant de
reprendre j'ai repris je suis resté coi
une semaine et je me suis mis en arrêt
après parce que ça faisait un moment
déjà que j'avais un petit souci
bah que les tous les délires de deux
contrôles au faciès de racisme de il y
avait beaucoup de comportements qui me
gênait dans la police et donc l'argent
levé plus de reconnaître en fait donc là
là là là là vous là vous dites que voilà
vous aviez la police ça vous
correspondez pas vous avez vraiment vu
des comportements comme ça mais en fait
je sais apprécier moi j'étais en arrêt
et quand juste pour préciser au moment
où je suis parti sur l'épreuve était
déjà en arrêt j'étais en déni
complètement avec l'institution j'étais
chez moi je travaillais plus à ce moment
là moi il ya des comportements qui m'ont
gêné qui ont fait que ça fait un moment
et encore une fois je crache pas sur
l'institution je parle de certains
comportements que j'ai vue opérées
auprès des personnes qui représente
l'institution
mais quand une femme vient déposer
plainte à 18h55 et que le plantier qui
finit à 19 heures il dit il va vient de
déposer plainte pour viol elle pratique
le platier il dit elle n'aurait pas pu
déposer plainte pour viol alors pas pu
se faire violer un autre jour ça c'est
des comportements que je cautionne pas
faire des concours d'amande sur le
groupe what that de la brigade c'est à
dire c'est quoi ça les concours de vente
pendant gros ouais moi j'ai mis santé a
enfin terrasser les amendes moi j'ai me
sentais à aujourd'hui moi j'en ai mis
deux sens je suis pas rentré pour ça je
suis pas rentré pour sa fin c'est quoi
comme beaucoup à la folie des oui moi
quand je suis rentré je suis rentré en
2017 dans la police quand je suis rentré
en plus je viens d'un endroit où je
n'aime pas trop la police voilà donc moi
j'ai pas d'à priori du tout devient
sartrouville
moi je suis rentré des sans abri je
viens d'un endroit qui me pas la police
je rentre dans la police on fait laissez
moi dire que non non non imposition de
mots qui est quand même un peu faudra me
laisser finir bon on va les aider
justement j'ai pas eu à priori parce que
je suis rentré en me disant je veux
faire des choses bien je vais changer
les choses je suis jeune je suis
dynamique je vais rentrer pour de bonnes
causes
pour faire quelque chose de bon je suis
rentré puis au bout d'un moment je me
suis heurté à pas mal de trucs pas mal
de comportement le manque de
reconnaissance
certains comportements ouais et
xénophobes en fait clairement il ya pas
mal de comportement c'est très fermé
d'esprit qui m'ont gêné c'est pas
l'institution
la police jurassienne et ouais j'ai été
victime de racisme s'est pas directement
en fait ces gens alors on va descendre
on va contrôler tes semblables ou bien
les chefs de brigade qui mettent des
trucs xénophobes sur facebook enfin et
ça ça va ça posera de problème sur quoi
sur l'islam simplement sur l'islam et
bien sûr du tout que ça te gêne pas de
faire des ajustements
mais justement les vidéos petite toque
de zoubir saissac et aussi déranger vos
collègues votre supérieur de la police
on va voir après aussi votre avis bien
entendu ça c'est rien ça c'est ma mère
qui au soir
c'est sympa café au café au carnaval je
suis dans le caca tnt pisté par sa mère
la salle des beats sa mère la [ __ ] phare
ça débile sa mère là
[Musique]
mais voilà alors alors ça nos peaux
mates vous allez donnez votre avis dans
l'instant et ça ça avec l'uniforme et
tout ça passe pas du tout assez désolant
que ces données pathétique désolant elle
a d'autres qualités c'est dommage qui
les exploitent en faisant ça et en
démystifiant et en donnant une image une
image lamentable de l'uniforme
l'uniforme mérite pas ça de voir ça
ouais ça me fait du mal parce que il est
il est issu de la diversité ce jeune
homme
et c'est bien qu'on ait des gens comme
lui d'un autre police et il y en a
beaucoup
faut savoir que la nasa c'est
l'administration où il ya le plus de
diversité
donc lorsqu'il dit que la police ait et
xénophobes racistes etc
ça c'est encore des clichés évidemment
parce qu on a 3 5000 policiers lorsqu'il
dit ça il jette l'opprobre sur trois
cent mille policiers et gendarmes et qui
travaille tous les jours à la sécurité
des citoyens donc l'entendre dire ça il
faut bien que ça n'aille je pense qu'il
va s'en aller effectivement je pense que
même qui va être révoqué
d'administration ces voix là ils
méritent pas d'être argentier de la
police ben oui parce que si vous voulez
c'est dommage il est plein de qualités
ce berceau c'est dommage parce que la
police a besoin de renouveau utiliser
les réseaux sociaux c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et d'ailleurs darmanin a
abondé dans ce sens puisqu'il a lancé un
chat donc ça veut dire que la policière
la police a envie d'évoluer sur ces
sujets de la communication mais c'est
dommage que tu te ridiculise et que tu
ridiculise la maison police en faisant
ce que tu fais la transmission en temps
des souvenirs que vous ridiculiser la
maison police par bruno pomart et par
vos parents vos supérieurs yacine
allemand qui aurait été fait sur la
patente de l'igpn l'inspection générale
de la police nationale est ce que vous
savez qui est à l'origine de
signalements déjà vous avez été dénoncé
par un collègue très saint connec moi je
sais qui en fait moi pendant ça fait
plusieurs semaines
il ya des groupes de deux collègues
enfin qu'ils sont en train de se faire
une ligne ils font des groupes et on au
trio web montre moi et ça m'aide et
story ça ressort enfin pas mal d'infos
personnelles sur moi sur ma famille le
compte instagram 26 heures qui a 13 ans
ça va super lent et je vois pas comme
fin ils sont super soudée pour faire
tomber je comprends pas les urgences
qu'aujourd'hui la mettra je pense
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui franchement
en france la police des hlm à traiter
c'est un jeune de 25 ans qui fait des
tic toc et franchement c'est votre avis
donc par votre position et votre passé
je comprends que vous défendez 15e
l'institution n'y a pas de problème mais
encore une fois je me suis aussi des
travers le monde et si durement et
deuxièmement
moi de ce que je vois sur les réseaux
les commentaires des gens qui me suivent
je reçois énormément de messages tu
donne une bonne image de la police
ça se rapproche de la population etc il
n'y a pas de haine dans ce que je fais
il n'y a rien de mal n'y a rien de
méchant dans ce que je fais et
franchement si on peut dire c'est que
justement des bavures et que ça fracasse
quelqu'un ça fait des cagnottes litchi
mais moi qui fais des vidéos qui
essayent de véhiculer un message de paix
là par contre acharnement arcic je sais
c'est pas un message l'épaisse un
message de file physique il faut faire
mannequin fois l'ukraine après ça c'est
une vidéo parmi tant d'autres se
dérangent qu'ils soient policiers
ardennais one quand on voit les images
on voit monsieur que vous bien fait de
sa personne qui est fait pour les
rencontres de tous ordres mais sûrement
pas pour être dans la police ça fait
penser un petit peu de même il est
policier
ici les policiers c'est ça qui est
génial c'est moi votre avis et
j'aimerais votre ami chez vous vous est
ce que ça vous dérange qu'un policier
fasse de la télé réalité aucun policier
faisait tic toc mois mais si ces faits
derrière mais je me fais l'avocat du
diable
quant aux ou birdy oui moi je fais ça et
ça permet aussi peut-être de me
rapprocher des jeunes idheap
hauts-de-seine et sympathique the policy
possède de plus voire faire passer des
messages
c'est pas complètement idéaux ce qu'ils
disent ou bien nicolas pernikoff
sélections qui dit au début il a
complètement décrédibilisé la police oui
c'est ça j'ai des moments donnés je vois
il apporte la police bienvenue en cg pas
discréditée moi non mais je suis pas en
train de vous juger mais pourquoi vous
êtes devenu policier en 2010 est passé
de 10 francs chez nous et il en est
d'accord mais question là là les
policiers s'engagent les policiers l'ont
bien leur vie ils s'en prennent plein la
gueule en ce moment je n'ai sont engagés
mais le problème c'est pourquoi vous
rendez compte quand vous ridiculiser la
police a j'oubliai qu'est ce que vous
répondez mais moi je fais choqué me
ridiculiser la police mais pas du tout
quand j'ai fait comme je disais à tout à
l'heure quand je suis comme moi je vois
les messages des gens qui me suivent
mais les gens qui m'apprécient sais pas
si c'est paris c'est pas de les lire il
ya 67 millions d'habitants il n'y a pas
dix mille le mec sur le réseau réseaux
sociaux il faut arrêter d'accord mais
dans les 65 habitants magnin la
naissance dans les soixante huitards et
sincèrement je suis sûr que c'est mitigé
moi de ce que j'ai en retour ces deux
bons tours guillaume une image positive
je véhicule la paix je ris pas des
familles je vais utiliser qu aucun
message de haine
j'ai même des collègues policiers qui
sont en arrêt depuis un moment qui
m'envoyait on n'en peut plus ça fait du
bien tu donnes du renouveau j'ai pas mal
de messages positifs je dis pas ça parce
que
john elkann cité depuis depuis
aujourd'hui non mais au bout d'un moment
je pression voir les choses réelles
suivre sûr sûr sûr le combat
qu'est ce que vous avez comme on savait
qu'il y avait vos collègues policiers
qui savait que vous alliez voir subir ce
soir et vous donnez moi bien que qui
serait que personne n'était d'accord
avec lui que c'était lamentable d'avoir
un élément comme ça dans la police
nationale tout simplement et c'est
regrettable encore une fois parce que ce
garçon est issu de la diversité j'aime
bien appuyé sur le mot parce que c'était
pourtant voué à l'inscrire dans la
police oui mais justement non mais c'est
vachement important
son comportement la nuit mais de façon
évidente à l'image de la police on en a
pas besoin
quelqu'un l'a fait remarquer tout à
l'heure c'est dommage encore une fois
c'est dommage de faire un plus des clips
puisque les clips où on met des claques
dans la tronche en montant une
interpellation c'est pas ça la police
nationale s'il ya des mecs qui dérape
dans la police nationale
ils sont sanctionnés le clip haut en bas
on te voit en effet un mec ça veut dire
un contrôle se fait 36 ans la maison
dont je la connais et je la connais
encore dominé auch pas si si si si si
une vidéo 30 au club sicilien soutenir
il se trouve que c'est dommage je sais
nous arrange ses caricatures est là pour
nous ou bien moi moi le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que vous n'étiez pas heureux
dans la police oui c'est possible et que
je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez faire
en fait j'ai l'impression
vous vous êtes trompé de casting c'est à
dire vous êtes arrivés à prier vous
aviez un truc dans la tête vous attardez
d'entreprise et des annonces est pas
tout à fait comme ça parce que quand
vous démarrez au début oubliés avec vous
dise
vous disiez tout à l'heure oui dans la
police il ya des comportements
xénophobes
il ya des comportements qui me plaisent
pas ça vous comprenez bien je joue bien
ça peut encore plus gêné que vos vidéos
tik tok que vous disiez ça avance c'est
pour ça que moi pour moi il ya de plus
gros problèmes à traiter
moi quand je suis rentré dans la police
parce que l'intérêt j'avoue il ya pas
mal de commentaires sur les réseaux
ouais ça recrute des cassos la revue à
la baisse juste pour info quand j'ai
passé le concours j'étais dans les
meilleures classes et sur l'épreuve
psychotechniques sur les épreuves
physiques vous êtes sur des airs et sur
leur et pierre d'être policier oui
j'étais fier d'être ici les gens
pourquoi ce revirement alors pourquoi ce
revirement parce que de moi mais moi je
vous parle pas de la saison je vois dans
mon expérience de moi même je me suis
heurté à certains comportements à
certaines mentalités ou au bout d'un
moment je me suis dit mais quand je
commence à me lever le matin j'ai une
boule au ventre chorale pour aller au
boulot je me sens plus à ma place mais
tous partir on reste pas dans la police
savait comment ça marche et statutaires
pour démissionner sans payer si je pars
maintenant je paye 12000 euros je vais
être honnête avec vous je roule pas sur
l'or gc ca les 12000 euros c'est ça si
vous partez maintenant je le dis aux
téléspectateurs séparent maintenant
s'ils démissionnent
il doit payer 2000 euros je ne sais pas
je roule pas sur l'or mais sur
et nos services connaissaient combien ou
bien juste une petite chose est ce que
c'est vrai que quand vous êtes arrivé
dans la police matin vous pensiez vous
faire si vos places yoplait autant
d'espoir h à la maison ici on n'est pas
chez vous s'il vous plaît zoubir quand
vous êtes arrivé dans la police je crois
que vous rêviez de faire des grandes
enquêtes
vous avez été un petit peu déçue au
début c'est ça aussi basique wacom comme
travail au quotidien moi je suis rentré
en brigade de jours de cours à la
desserte est pas prêt je suis rentré en
brigade de juin police secours ouais et
moi par la suite après avoir au début ça
se passait super bien et peut même par
la suite je voulais passer bloc au pgi
je voulais pas laisser ça me plaisait je
voulais passer le concours officiels etc
j'étais vraiment j'étais vraiment motivé
et c'est au fur et à mesure en fait
c'est parti d'une blessure en service
nous laisser passer j'ai fait un
accident de moto survenu au boulot je
boitais plein de pizzas partout des
croûtes de partout je fais une
interpellation qui se passe bien je me
blesse un peu et quand je rentre en gros
c'est décidé les 6es du kiss et du cat 2
ça veut dire qu'il y avait trois ou
quatre jours de tables de jours de repos
et c'était au troisième jour je vais
voir mon gestionnaire jeudi écoutez je
suis blessé donc le lendemain vu que
j'étais au poste au planton je peux
rester debout donc pour pas [ __ ] le
bordel sur les services je me suis dit
je vais rester demain même si je boite
par contre après je me mets en arrêt
oise oublier tu fais chier
et puis par l idée qu après des je me
suis mis en arrêt on m'enlève du groupe
pareil ça commence à envoyer des piques
ways où il fait si fin j'ai pas fait
quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait un manque de
reconnaissance alors que j'étais motivé
ce qui fait mon taf je tenais mon
énergie parce qu'il faut savoir quand on
est motivé on vit police en manche
police on vit police je me suis dit mais
non j'ai pas signé pour ça en fait pour
la gratitude pour le manque de
reconnaissance tout simplement et c'est
là après que ça a commencé quand je fais
des projets à côté des shootings du
mannequinat les moqueries les brimades
c'est très fermé d'esprit quand on fait
quelque chose qui est pas se mettre en
congé de maladie sourire franchement et
faire de la télé réalité à côté
vis-à-vis des collègues c'est quand même
pas très clean là on en est clair que
moi mais là j'étais pas sur le même
sujet là on parlait lui non mais je veux
montrer la vidéo qui pose vraiment
problème
c'est le cas notamment de celle ci qui
pose problème ça débite sa mère la [ __ ]
avait mis sa mère la [ __ ] et leur
investiture que la reine du pire
voilà alors ça c'est une des vidéos qui
pose vraiment problème s'il vous plaît
et je vous parlerais chez vous oui donc
qui ça c'est vraiment la vidéo qui pose
problème
bruno sallèles vous pose problème ça là
ab oui oui totalement et toutes celles
où il y à un uniforme pour moi c'est
tourner en dérision la fonction de
policier paul finale voilà moi je suis
ouvert
moi j'ai des policiers par exemple aux
oubliettes aurait pu devenir et j'en ai
deux sens dans mon association qui
bossent qui vont au contact des gosses
qui font plein d'action pour les gamins
ça c'est hyper positif ça s'est donné
une belle image a pris ça pour moi ce
n'est pas une bonne image de moi on va
on va avoir votre avis à un zoom bien
vous allez couture et nicolas pernikoff
nord mais moi ce que j'aimerais
comprendre parce qu'il est policier
depuis 2010 est il a fait des congés
sans solde il a fait des arrêts maladie
nico vous a été policier combien de
temps réalité sur le terrain
il a été policier pendant trois ans sur
le terrain trois ans attend sur le
terrain me manque mais trop bien ça
suffit revoir est d'accord mais comment
vous pouvez autant paris de la police
est alors surtout ma question c'est que
vous ne comprenez pas qu'il faut
demander une autorisation à votre
employeur pour changer de métier ça
marche pas comme ça je vous expliquais
pour la démission c'est pas c'est pas la
démission mais au moins demander
l'autorisation a été obtenue
l'autorisation basque au voyage était en
rupture
c'est à dire de nicolas pernikoff c est
ce que vous comprenez que vous auriez dû
demander à vos supérieurs et les
prévenir que vous allez lire les princes
de l'amour il entend alors des paniers c
les textes
moi je vous parle de ce que je pense
vraiment de mon expérience je vais pas
dire c'est pas ça alors c'est ça les
textes ses écrits les allées comme une
faute là dessus j'ai comme une fois de
la soirée d'accord là dessus vous avez
commis me suis donné le bateau montre
bien vous dites pour reprendre vos mots
que ça il ya une fracture avec la police
d'accord que aujourd'hui vous avez
constaté que la police était un petit
peu raciste homophobe mais là il a l'air
de vous servir l'uniforme
donc pourquoi fanfaronner après sur les
réseaux alors vous dites qu'il ya
vraiment eu parce que je vais juste
préciser le passage c'est que le
cantique top je n'ai pas créé maintenant
ça faisait un petit moment que j'avais
le petit homme c'est violent je faisais
sélectionnons fille cherche l'amour est
un oiseau alors passé surtout un essai
vidéo à date de quand ces vidéos et
dates de ses pas le problème ça c'est
bien mais françois
aaron avec l'uniforme je veux comprendre
oui mais c'est moi ce que je désire dit
ce qu'il a dit zoubir c'est qu'il se
sert aussi de benito il ya deux choses 1
parce que je pense que voilà vous voilà
et puis vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est aussi pour montrer une autre image
de la police parce que moi à plusieurs
reprises j'ai essayé de renouer avec le
avec le avec la boîte à plusieurs
reprises j'ai essayé node renouer donc
ce genre de vidéo d'un mois fin après
c'est mon humour ses propres à moi il ya
beaucoup de gens et quand j mais surtout
que je mets humour je m'achetais guillon
c'est à dire quand je dis prendre des
numéros à ce moment là franchement en ce
moment j'ai plus de chance était chez
moi c'est tel confinement
j'ai plus de chances de choper le
coville que choper des numéros je n'ai
pas chopé des numéros j'ai jamais choqué
numéro sur des contrôles
donc c'est vraiment de sens de l'humour
kelly moi ma question c'est est-ce que
le fait d'avoir été dans cette hausse
dans ce commissariat et vous avez vu des
choses qui ne vous qui ne vous plaît pas
est ce que ça vous n'êtes pas en train
de faire une généralité moi c'est ça que
je trouve dommage c'est de faire une
généralité d'un truc que vous avez vécu
vous personnellement
et ça je trouve ça vraiment malheureux
après le fait que vous ayez fait cette
télé réalité
franchement on va dire la vérité vous
voulez déjà quitté ce travail vous vous
en fichez complètement et vous avez le
sentiment que j'ai aussi rousse hervé
notre éditeur vont attirer les nanas et
voilà c'est ce que moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'en fait ça fait des semaines que tu
veux quitter la police dit la vérité
moi ça fait un moment que le propos mais
c'est un peu tôt mais c'est un peu tard
et chaleureux moment là j'ai lâché l'âge
et là j'ai vu monde arabe mais cet
enseignement pour moi c'est comme ça
parce que je trouve qu'elle compte
acheter de nouveaux souliers pour la
rentrée nos propres mots mais non je
trouve vraiment dommage et encore une
fois pour l'image moi je reçois des
tweets salariés de copains des jeunes et
les moins jeunes et cetera c'est un
câble en accablant sur quoi vrai est
accablant
carrez ab oui oui oui il aurait pu faire
encore une fois la télé réalité les
princes et princesses à la limite si
l'administration l'autorisé à le faire
pourquoi pas c'est qu'elles n'ont pas
autorisé ou pas non non je pense pas
qu'elle sera sujet déjà quand j'ai fait
mr ile de france il ya toujours
et donc quand été missionnaire trop
c'est juste pour dire que peu importe ce
que je faisais ça gênait tant que ça
d'âge à partir du moment où sa dérive de
la police après c'est sûr ça va faire
polémique c'est des fonctions
régaliennes c'est la police donc
forcément ça fait polémique
ça va pas faire l'unanimité mais à
partir du moment où je faisais quelque
chose qui dérivait du milieu police l'a
plaisait pas s'ils savaient pas ils
étaient six avaient pas été la télé dans
tous les cas ça aurait pu être ok s'il y
avait des comportements déviants
c'est à toi de dénoncer parce que
l'administration police n'est pas
parfaite moi j'ai jamais dit ça je
défends les policiers cordes et âmes
mais si les policiers ne se comporte pas
comme il faut elles sont à dénoncer
l'administration le fait c'est le faible
on a et tu le sais bien près de 1500
dossiers à l'igpn de fonctionnaires qui
sont soit révoqué soit avec des blancs
avec ses terres ce qui risque d'arriver
d'ailleurs ce qui était d'ailleurs assez
bien je vous trouve absolument charmant
très souriant très solaire et
sympathique quelqu'un sur les réseaux
sociaux ça me gêne pas le mélange des
genres après tout on voit gabriela
talent qui fait d installer avec des
influences euse bon pourquoi pas après
par rapport à l'institution
moi j'ai l'impression surtout vous
chercher en fait vous êtes une sommeil
work in progress
en fait vous savez par vous avez envie
de chine et vous avez envie de kif et
vous avez envie d'être peut naître
célèbre de faire le buzz
la bri où je regrette en velcro nitiéma
vous avez 25 ans et ce après moi je
trouve que c'est tout à fait normal
en revanche moi ce que je voudrais
savoir parce que vous êtes arrivé ici
souriant et au fur et à mesure où vous
êtes fermé donc je vais voir si la
police ne l'avait pas poser problème
moi je trouve que je serai toujours
autant là mais si la police vous n'avez
rien dit si tu t'es pas ces crèmes
est ce que vous vous auriez dénoncé la
même manière ces choses là aujourd'hui
sur la police et sur l'institution leur
assise et contrôler c'est des choses
c'est des choses que j'ai déjà dénoncé
j'ai même fait des rapports dessus c'est
ce que je disais juste avancer des
choses que j'ai déjà dénoncé
donc nous on va penser que je profite
aujourd'hui comme ici où ça va vraiment
un impact voyez ce que je vais dire mais
en fait je profite pas du jeu profite
pas de ce buzz a dans tous les cas je
les dénonce et déjà médiatiquement bas
là j'ai eu l'autorisation de le faire
mais si j'avais pu le faire avant bien
sûr que j'aurais plus je leur ai tout à
venir vous dire vous pensez que c'est
terminé pour vous la police on va pas se
mentir on m a dit si c'était leur envie
de vous faire virer j'ai envie de
chercher autre chose
d'accord vous devrez faire quoi jusqu'à
présent vous avez surtout envie de kent
[Rires]
je vais les choses allaient désormais
s'ouvrir
[Applaudissements]
je n'aime pas ma mère elle regarde cette
expulsion
non mais voilà ce qu'il en est ouvrez un
vrai je cherche à empêcher d'autres
milieux après quitte à toi apprendra taf
alimentaire pour le moment mais je sais
que j'ai envie de me tourner vers quitte
même le cinéma le mannequinat je sais
que c'est plus à l'aise dans ce genre de
trucs il ya les cadors qui rigole pour
une dernière question de minutes un
presque excusé moi vous êtes peut-être
le chef don balon son poste mais ici
c'est touche pas à mon poste à une forme
ça me choque parce qu'il fait comme le
dit géraldine on a du mal en france avec
le mélange des genres aux états unis et
pourtant dieu sait que les flics sont
plus à la dure là bas qu'en france il ya
plein de vidéos humoristiques et pour
les salles et madaya près sur le fond il
ya quelque chose que je trouve
dramatique que démontre cette histoire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour un jeune
socialement c'est plus valorisant d'être
un candidat de télé réalité
certains policiers et ça veut dire quoi
sert que les policiers ils sont sous
payés ils sont mais parce que tout à
l'heure quand il a parlé de deux
d'estimé de soi fins de reconnaissance
des autres vous avez un manque de
reconnaissance et c'est dommage que vous
faites un travail qui est formidable
vous n'êtes pas assez payés vous n'êtes
pas assez reconnus par la cera et et
c'est dommage que ça non plus valorisant
de faire les princes de la moitié des
policiers non mais je suis un peu
d'accord
j'oublie rallymen en velin en vrai c'est
ce que tu es en train de nous dire et
c'est ça qui est grave et là un signe tu
sais rien de mieux ne pas faire mais
c'est vrai dire c'est que noah c'est
vrai qu'il ya plein de jeunes ya plein
de petits et tout-petits bacchini stage
hormis les policiers c'est génial voilà
ccc je cherchais mon rêve est
aujourd'hui tu as l'impression que tu
nous dis c'est plus valorisant ce que
disait guillaume dette dont les princes
et les princesses de l'amour que d'être
policier m'a des sculptures sont déjà
j'aime pas le politiquement correct donc
clairement si on parle financièrement si
quelqu'un perd ce dans la télé ça paye
plus que la police
la menace est menacé c'est factuel là
c'est pas moi c'est factuel regardez
castaldi prendre exemple sur un marshall
qui était dans la police était fan de
théâtre il a fait il a aidé dans la
police
il a d'abord il a appris son métier de
comédien il aimait le cinéma le théâtre
il a arrêté la police il a parlé sur la
bbc qu'il a envie de faire autre chose
mais il envie de faire danser les débats
ne soient pas dans le bon sens et tout
juste joue bien moi ce que je te dis
c'est que tu vas pas nous dire il faut
aussi il ya plein de jeunes qui te
regardent qui te coûte qui suivent je
peux pas dire que dans la police avec
des pourris aux sahraouis non mais je
les dis ça parce que ça j'aime aussi me
soutiennent bah oui moi j'ai en fait moi
je parle de la des mecs super moi je
m'entraîne et il le sait et bordeaux je
m'entraîne pas la girouette je
m'entraîne avec un pote à moi
voilà donc qui l'amène karim qui avec
exceptionnelle et c'est vrai que là bas
il ya un mois je vais je suis allé au
raid et j'ai eu la chance d'y aller
c'est qu'il ya il ya là bas ça parle pas
de religion
ça parle pas de deux tu t'es tu étais un
tt tt voilà des musulmans des juifs
la foule est là bas mais s'il ya des
bons mecs qui étaient pas des bons mecs
c'est ce qui est absolument ils sont
tous dans le même sens que moi c'est ça
que j'aimais ce qui est dommage
cyril c'est que ce garçon il a plein de
talent dans ce qu'il fait sur tille
hadorn
mais les utilisent pas n'utilisez pas le
produit policiers c'est terrible quand
c'est terrible pour notre image je
t'assure tu as tu as de l'impac auprès
des jeunes et à mieux mais et de
l'impact positif et ne casse pas une
profession comme la nôtre qui est déjà
hyper compliqué dans la société actuelle
tu le sais voilà les policiers ne mérite
pas ça il ya 3 5 me le mec qui travaille
pour la sécurité de ce pays pour la
sécurité des citoyens
tu peux pas faire ça c'est pas vrai tu
as tu as d'autres total à exploiter les
ailleurs bonjour moi je verrai si je
sais c'est pas subjectivité dans tous
les cas c'est un avis qui va être
subjectif mais moi je sais que auprès de
certaines personnes je donne pas une
mauvaise image
j'en suis convaincu soupire toit des
ovules et la pêche je véhicule quelque
chose de plus je vécus pas quelque chose
de montréal c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas
agressive n'empêche que voix et même
dans les princes de l'avoir je trouve ça
hyper respectueux l'oignon surtout ne
vois là qu'est vraiment et/ou doutez
bien habillé tu mets des mocassins sans
chaussettes
[Rires]
mais l'évocation juste dernière chose
qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire tu
veux quitter la police oui et tu veux
faire quoi maintenant tu veux faire de
la télé de faire faire des vidéos être
influenceurs et faire les princes de
l'amour je suis en pleine réflexion ça a
lâché que j'ai envie de rebondir dans
l'audiovisuel et bah écoute
franchement quand je dois en faire un
think tank team signe un contrat de
chroniqueurs sénat ba écoute ci alors je
vais te dire si tu étais pas bien payé
dans la police si dieu